[Música]
hablamos ahora de economía está con
nosotros en el estudio jorge hurtado
jorge buenas noches dedicamos este
espacio economía para hablar de cifras
de colombia y de cómo van a recibir las
cuentas el nuevo gobierno la nueva
administración que llega a la casa de
nariño santiago dice que varios
analistas apuntan a que el nuevo
gobierno que llegue a la presidencia de
colombia va a encontrar las arcas y
números rojos aunque la administración
de iván duque entrega las arcas con un
crecimiento económico que según la ocde
es el mayor de la región incluso sobre
economías como chile argentina o brasil
ese crecimiento no cubre grandes brechas
de desigualdad pobreza y desempleo por
ejemplo el desempleo de bando que lo
recibe el 94 por ciento y lo entregará
cerca del 12,1 por ciento mientras que
la pobreza que estaba en 26,9 por ciento
en 2021 se ubicó en 39 3% lo que
significa que unos 19,6 millones de
colombianos subsisten con alrededor de
350 mil pesos mensuales esos son unos 89
dólares consultamos con el economista
alejandro godoy sobre cómo reciben las
arcas o gobierno y esto nos dijo que
reciben las arcas del gobierno de una
manera bastante en estado comatoso
podríamos decir
precisamente por varios escándalos de
corrupción aunque se han establecido
obviamente pues con dos años de pandemia
también bastante complejos en los temas
de subsidio de mejora de condiciones de
la población un desempleo galopante
importantísimo por supuesto el tema de
cerrar las brechas en el mercado laboral
cuando vemos que colombia es uno de los
países de américa latina que en este
contexto continúa teniendo una tasa de
desempleo por encima de los dos dígitos
lo cual considera y se establece como
uno de los mayores retos por supuesto
además de eso uno de los grandes
desafíos cuando hablamos de las arcas
del estado tienen que ver con una cada
vez mayor brecha entre las zonas urbanas
y rurales y los dos también hablado han
hablado que para la mejora de todo lo
que tiene que ser ese tema de las arcas
del estado realmente también hay que
hacer una nueva reingeniería como nación
en todo lo que conlleva a tener
específicamente una mayor
descentralización del estado porque hay
uno de los grandes retos que va a tener
el nuevo presidente de colombia es el
déficit fiscal en el que se encuentra el
país sin duda esta cifra se disparó tras
la pandemia en varios países de américa
latina y colombia no fue la excepción la
deuda se aumentó para atender la crisis
sanitaria y al cierre del 2021 en
colombia se ubicó sobre los 70 billones
de pesos el 7,1 por ciento del producto
interno bruto una cifra que si bien es
inferior respecto al 2020 es de suma
preocupación para varios analistas
asimismo el alza de los precios que es
un fenómeno global consecuencia de los
desequilibrios tras la pandemia de
grabados con la guerra en ucrania
representa otro gran reto para los
colombianos para mayo del 2022 la
variación anual del índice de precios al
consumidor fue
9,07 por ciento este aumento afecta el
gasto de los consumidores sobre todo los
hogares con ingresos bajos según un
reporte de la ocde los precios de los
alimentos en colombia subieron un 26%
con respecto hace un año mientras que el
salario mínimo solamente aumentó un 10%
a nuestro invitado le pedimos que nos
resumiera los tres principales retos
para la nueva administración y esto
comentó el primero evidentemente tiene
que ver con la recaudación con la
tributación que es muy importante algo
que es poco popular es decir ampliar la
base pero un amanecer ahí veremos aunque
aquí en colombia el tema del banco de la
república tiene una independencia grande
el segundo tiene que ver con el mercado
laboral colombia desde hace años no ha
logrado bajar en el tema de
indicadores del mercado laboral de dos
dígitos y por ende es uno de los retos
más grandes en una sociedad
desesperanzada sobre todo en los más
jóvenes en el campo laboral que no dicen
encuentran mayores oportunidades y el
tercer reto en este caso particular
tiene que ver con dos frentes realmente
importantes para colombia de un lado
cuando
informes de la fao por ejemplo han
establecido que colombia tiene un riesgo
alto en cuanto a que más de 20 millones
de personas no logren tres comidas de
acceso es algo bastante grave y por ende
eso va de la mano de la pobreza porque
en este caso particular ni más ni menos
entonces estamos hablando de una
situación estructural de algo que ya
ocurrió hace varias décadas y que será
uno de los mayores retos para ver si la
gobernabilidad y el indicador de
favorabilidad de quien gane las
elecciones va a ser de largo alcance
para tratar de medir estas promesas que
ha tenido durante su campaña muchas
gracias jorge punto final a esta
especial de economía sobre la economía
colombiana estamos listos para el debate
en donde también hablaremos de colombia
de cara a las elecciones